we are experimenting with some name
changes and variations on the channel so
it's all process trying to optimize and
be the best channel so we realize that
our channel just being Sam and Nico all
one word all lowercase is not very good
branding Sam and needle so Neagle is the
next alternative but we held off on that
because it's really cool and we want to
wait for the right time to drop it also
expect an icon change in the near future
are you this guys the first two videos
they get hundred thousand views in a row
we get call Michael a new camera my god
Canon for me Canon a TD
oh I opened it upside down dude these
are the nicest camera bags I know just
bags we got a net Nuttall frame 1 DX
mark 2 and then 11 to 24 alright see
look at this is the new lens here it's a
hair it's a tiny little hair from a tiny
of that animal let's test out this new
lens let's bring it for a ride here we
go guys
new lens yeah alright how's that look
good whoa that's such a big bulbous lens
here's the old one it's a full that's a
full frame 11 mil well that's an aps-c
11 well that's a little crazy at 6k case
you have something do you like to touch
it I would like to touch your cultures
corridor the noodle horrid or what
you're going what's stupid the same Neko
channel isn't San Diego it's corridors
then why don't we just go back to see -
it's now the second channel corridor 0
corridor 360 do you know why they called
the xbox 360 the Xbox 360 the real
reason is because the Xbox original Xbox
one came out when the PlayStation 2 came
out so in the next Xbox wanted to come
out they couldn't call it the Xbox 2
because the PlayStation was at
PlayStation 3 and satellite goes a
generation behind so they also needed a
3 in their title but they couldn't call
the Xbox 3
came up with the next most recognizable
number that begins with 3 which is
apparently 360 so that's why it's funny
it's pretty good only arbitrary favorite
alternate channel name yeah what if you
made up a word
this is not a gift alone from canon yeah
experiment with some new lenses new
camera work for the salmon eco channel
and the corridor channel exactly
you'll notice that every single lens
says marketing on it sorry guys we are
actively marketing right now apologies
for that
all those corporate lens industry
product placement videos you see this is
one of them macro 100 let's do this if
you want to see something really really
close up alright so this property pretty
wonky looking boom yeah gross right like
a kid in Candyland goes what we got badd
60 frames per second at 1080 which is
great and then the 1d x 4k 60 frames per
second and 120 frames 1080
are you excited Carmichael I'm very
excited
and let's switch cameras so here a
corridor we make our living on YouTube
it's important for us to study the
algorithms that suggest videos and put
your videos in front of new viewers and
kind of how the whole system works
because the more we understand that and
learn that the better we can expand our
audience the salmon eco channel's gone
through a pretty big evolution this past
couple of months of it I'll take it was
all about Greenville
you shooting a little bit less but it's
all just a little bit better oh I am the
camp a third of our audience watching
Sam and Nico wasn't subscribed to the
channel a month ago we did a big
subscription push we had a couple
segments of being speaking directly to
camera asking people to subscribe and we
did some little end cards that just
would politely say consider subscribing
and it works break now we saw something
interesting happen I expected the
percentage of unsubscribed viewers
yep previously with 33% I expected it to
go down maybe 30 maybe even 25% but
something interesting happened instead
the percentage of unsubscribed viewers
on the channel
but then the percentage actually went up
we went up from 33% unsubscribe 37%
unsubscribed that's really strange with
thousands and thousands of new
subscribers we're getting more people
who are unsubscribe to the channel so
why is that and how does the YouTube
algorithm play into that I have a bit of
a theory now this is pure speculation
YouTube's algorithm is secret we don't
know how it works and we can only look
at the numbers on our computer screens
to figure it out
so take this with a grain of salt but I
think that because the algorithm saw an
uptick in engagement and subscribers it
flipped that little switch inside the
system that decided to put our content
in front of even more viewers in front
of even more people it would make sense
that the algorithm would notice content
bringing in viewers and therefore put
that content in front of even more
viewers and rank it up in search results
and suggested videos and all that kind
of stuff so in other words by increasing
our subscriber base the algorithm then
put our content in front of even more
viewers thereby increasing our
percentage of unsubscribed viewers
sounds backwards but it worked so when
you guys are browsing YouTube and you're
looking at different channels
take a moment and look at how they're
doing your thumbnails their titles their
strategies everybody has all these
different ideas as to what works the
best and if you have any ideas yourself
feel free to share them with us because
we're all just trying to figure it out
you